[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous dans le cadre
de cinq à dix spéciales municipal nous
recevons ce matin marcellin nadeau
bonjour bonjour à la librairie bonjour
aux auditrices et auditeurs de radio
martinique la première salutations
singulier auprès auprès shooting auprès
chopin alors vous êtes candidat à votre
succession
pourquoi vous représentez je crois que
nous avons lancé un certain nombre de
projets avec une ambition réelle celle
d'une refondation de notre commune et je
crois qu'il est important effectivement
de poursuivre la tâche est de faire en
sorte avec tous les jalons soit posée de
manière à ce que prêcheur retrouve la
voix de l'attractivité d'un vrai
développement durable et d'une dynamique
au profit de després shot in et des
prêts chotin d'aujourd'hui et celles
issues de demain vous l'annoncé déjà
quand même que 2020 ce sera votre
dernière mandature
absolument je crois que je me présente
effectivement pour la dernière fois
c'était déjà un peu annoncé parce que
j'estime que c'est vrai que trois
mandatures c'est à dire 18 ans c'est
déjà pas mal pour impulser un vrai
projet de territoire
maintenant je fais le pari de la
jeunesse autour de moi il est sont
nombreuses et nombreux celles et ceux
qui peuvent poursuivre la tâche et je
crois que nous avons quand même en
quelques pas comme dirait jacques
roumain chaque nuit qui ne doit faire
son nid dans la vie je crois que je fais
le mien dans la fille du pêcheur
il faudra s'y préparent et effectivement
la transmission et et préparer la relève
en quelques semaines vous avez déjà
décisive avait déjà des personnes en vue
il ya déjà des jeunes qui se détache
oui je suis à des gens très intéressants
maintenance et par un processus
démocratique celles et ceux qui devront
demain nous représenter seront désignés
vous n'avez pas de
vous n'avez pas d'opposant déclaré en
tout cas dans la commune la liste on
nous parlons ça fait la deuxième fois
que cela se présente en 2014 était déjà
le cas vous fait l'unanimité dans votre
commune non je ne crois pas que je fasse
l'unanimité et bien évidemment déjà bon
le thym dans l'espace c'est dès qu'il ya
des gens bons que quoi qu'il arrive
qu'ils ne seront jamais favorable à à
marcelin nadeau et puis à sa pipe on
peut avoir des évolutions des gens qui
aujourd'hui sont pour demain contre des
gens qui étaient hier compte qu'ils sont
pour aujourd'hui je vois que ses volumes
et je crois que nous essayons je pense
que les prix chutaient sont conscients
quand même deux on peut toujours faire
des erreurs nul n'est infaillible mais
je crois qu'ils sont quand même
conscient de la sincérité de notre
démarche et notre volonté notre
détermination à faire du prêcheur un
territoire prospère à l'occ l'oppression
comme beaucoup de territoires du roi
martinique est confronté à de réelles
difficultés alors le déplacement du
bourg la mise en sécurité des habitants
du bourg ce sera l'oeuvre de votre
mandature
moi je n'ai pas besoin de 2,9
extraordinaire moi je suis j'essaie de
répondre de façon concrète et
pragmatique aux réalités le prêcheur et
aujourd'hui et comme il ya d'ailleurs
confrontés une forte exposition au
risque notamment les risques littoraux
et le risque dollar
on ne peut pas rester comme ça les bras
croisés avant une communauté disparate
et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
pour moi
par conviction parce que je suis
fondamentalement un écologiste un
humaniste toute communauté fut elle la
plus petite qui disparaît est une perte
énorme pour l'humanité donc vous savez
je suis senti mentalement très attaché
au prêcheur qu'il a qu'un communauté toc
m'a vu grandir
c'est pour ça que je suis déterminé à
trouver les solutions justement pour que
notre communauté demeure en dépit de
tous les risques auxquels cette
communauté se de ce territoire et est
exposée c'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé avec le soutien de l'état le puc
aplanissent construction aménagement la
diane martinique est bien de lancer ce
projet qui permettra justement de mettre
les biens et les personnes à l'abri de
tout risque en faisant je veux dire
dépend déplaçant le bourg
les auteurs alors l'appel justement
l'appel à manifestation d attirer
concernant le déplacement du bourg a
suscité un certain nombre de critiques
quant au choix des architectes
certains disent qu'il y avait que des
architectes européens mais attendez
franchement il ya eu un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt publiées dont
tout le monde était au courant fête de
la musique qu'il savait seule une
architecture et nicaise s'est positionné
et un autre ou de guadeloupe
enfin franchement c'est pas de ma faute
de main sereine à dos si des architectes
martiniquais ne sont pas intéressés pour
x raisons ça peut être des raisons tout
à fait légitime s éditions rené de
défense est martiniquais n'ai pas
d'intérêts mais en tout cas celle qui
est qui s'est positionné me paraît très
intéressante et très motivé l éternel
maintenant elle est non on ne sait pas
encore puisque le jury doit se réunir le
18 février
ce que je retiens juifs effectivement il
faudrait que plus d'architectes man il
ya ceux et celles des architectes qui
sont déjà impliqués dans le projet ça
soit franck hubert jean camille petit
serge dunod ils sont déjà dedans mais
s'agissant des autres eh bien oui je
crois que ce serait bien que des
architectes martiniquais s'intéresse un
peu plus à des problématiques qui font
fondamental pour l'avenir de ce pays
marcellin nadeau je vous remercie bonne
journée à licques de nos programmes
merci
donc